PROFESSOR 1: When you hear
the word quality, what are
some specific things that come to mind?
And whether that could be a
particular patient experience
or a hospital experience that you were
at that helped you have a better--
better articulate your own
thoughts on what quality is.
PROFESSOR 2: Quality
is behind everything.
If we take now health
infrastructure, I have
that experience of contracting
people to build a hospital.
And they build it in the wrong way.
And imagine that it delayed the work
of health professional for six months.
We delay six months.
How many death are we going to have
because health professionals were
there and were not able to give care?
That's one.
Now, the money we lose because
we have to destroy and rebuild,
and the time we lose,
it's behind everything.
All the chain of service
and all the tools
we need to have to give the
proper service, behind all this,
starting with education, continue with
the quality, the behavior you have.
This is also something
that is very important.
All along that chain,
from infrastructure,
from the type of staff you have,
from the type of medicine you use,
for the equipment you use
to give that medicine,
from the way you talk to
the patient and you explain
and dialogue with the patient, from the
way you make the patient participate
in whole health, and from the way
you plan with the patient the way
it's going to--
the thing is going to pass through
to recover, or at which extent
he will recover, to make him participate
in the future handicap management
he will have.
All this need quality.
And if you miss one
point, either you will
see the patient will not contribute
to his part for his own health,
will not own his own health, or will
be harmed by what you are doing,
or by what others are doing.
So that means, at all
stage, you need people
to enter in the job to do the job,
to conclude the job with quality.